alors tu as eu des hauts et des bas dans
ta vie j'espère une interview à peine
down ce que tu préfères dans le cinéma
dans le fait de faire du cinéma ce qui
te plaît le plus c'est petit transforme
est-ce que tu détestes dans le cinéma je
n'étais pas si je ne peux rien détesté
du cimmérien du cinéma donc je te parle
du plateau cinéma pour moi c'est le
plateau c'est à dire t'as l'oeil de
caméras c'est à dire t'as pas le public
comme au théâtre mais tu es le courrier
c'est à dire que le telegraph que tu
m'as envoyé là bas qu'on la pop disparu
tu vois et alors il faut une passion
s'il faut de santé c'est ce que disait
kayak dix ans et puis tu y vas et à ce
moment là tu te dis il faut piquer juste
dedans toujours pourquoi parce que de
toute façon on va en faire plusieurs
celle qui sera choisie sera celle du
metteur en scène celle de l'opérateur
celle du cadreur éventuellement même
celui de l'ingénieur du son et celle de
l'acteur ne sent jamais prioritaire
donc il faut que tu te défonces à toutes
les prises et parce que de toute façon
tu ne peux pas une pièce tu peux de
gouré comme ça bon mais tu joues le soir
de voir comment cela s'est
définitivement cédé repartir le colis
envoyé le film de toi que tu préfères
ce que ''pour je peux pas qu'est ce que
tu veux te dit pas assez c'est cci six
mois par tous les films de toi que tu
m'aimes pas celui que tu es vraiment là
on s'est foutu de ma gueule oui parce
que quand vous dites à un moment donné
un peu de respect quand même je prends
moi gentil geoffroy je suis pas un chat
et puis j'aurais sûrement trop jeune et
trop code quoi bon justement je jouais
au théâtre j'avais fait la réalité des
autres et je n'avais pas tourné déjà
depuis plusieurs fois et la première
fois combien c'était on offre de tournai
souvenirs souvenirs
on y sent bien que c'était une
participation bombe je me suis dit tiens
j'étais tout contact avec hamid les
romains formidable j'ai tourné mes
souvenirs souvenirs
parfait et puis et puis on attend on
attend on attend pas finalement on va
pour tourner et j'arrive et à ce moment
là
d'abord il y avait d'autres qui avaient
pris les rôles dont 6 fait que bon je me
retrouvais un type comme ça
bon et puis on tourne d'abord le metteur
en scène odieux avec l'équipe avec les
gens déjà ça j'aime pas et deuxième bob
dunn moche had been mais on n'a pas le
droit de faire ça je suis tout ce que tu
veux tu bürki tout ce que tu veux mais
commune et bobonne non et je n'admets
pas ça mais je veux dire qu'on n'a pas
le droit se fout de la gueule des
acteurs jeu des acteurs c'est trop
fragile on n'a pas le droit de faire ça
un peu de politesse quand même un peu de
décence le plus grand moment de vue mais
tu as tu
si bâbord toute façon toujours plus
important des dix mots c'est sa mort tu
as fait un film avec gérard pirès qui
s'appelait erotissimo vrai et il sort
d'une femme qui est folle de son corps
est ce que dans les périodes et les
potes film a fait est ce que tu as
accepté de faire des films pornos mais
érotiques voire des pornos ses bras
ils n'ont aucun talent c'est qu'il faut
faire parce que vraiment vous vraiment
mais vraiment ils font tout antibes
aurait fait s'il avait été bien fait au
nom pour ça érotique disons soft on
aurait fait ou non érotiques dont je
veux dire que sensuelle et sensuelle oui
oui à tout un acteur un acteur c'est ça
leiter c'est que des grands réalisateurs
qui ont fait le film est sûrement déjà